[Music]
testing testing testing test ting tests
ting one two three
I'm saying ting because I listened to
the Drake's new album welcome to
congratulations podcast what's up my
babies I'm right here man I'm right here
and I'm right now what's that what was
that song right here right now I don't
know if that was by but it was super 80s
and 90s 90s I think congratulations the
podcast episode 8 is the first ever 8
episode that's amazing dude you guys
were doing it and we're doing it good
and we're doing it live and every
episode I feel like we're picking up
some steam and people are getting
involved more people are telling each
other about this this is like a cult
basically I'm starting a cult and it's
called congratulations and it started
with the plot it started with my
stand-up and then it moved over to the
podcast so pretty soon we'll all be in a
log cabin somewhere in Montana drinking
weird [ __ ] but I'm here and I'm in LA
and I've been in LA for about two weeks
that's a long time for me I've been off
the road because I shot my special and
and that's what's up and it's a
beautiful day the weather's beautiful la
is the best man I love the weather a
period that's why people say was your
favorite place LA cuz the weather that's
the answer
picked up my coffee today as I do every
day went to this cafe near my where I
pick up my prescriptions and [ __ ] not
telling you the ailments I got but I had
to go pick up had to go to the cafe had
to go to the cafe near my near my
prescription where I pick it up at the
CVS and every time I go to this cafe
there's this old man there super old and
he's one of the you know how coffee
shops always had like one weirdo um he's
always dressed like Indiana Jones his
father
hit like all beige he's like one of
those guys he has like 18 pockets on his
vest and he sets up like this table when
he puts this thing these stickers out
there and when you walk by if you make
eye contact he'll be like you know he'll
be like you should check this out and
hand you a sticker for some [ __ ]
thing and you're like okay cool and then
he starts talking about like countries
you've never been to but oh and he also
has the worst breath ever of all time so
that's cool
he'll talk and you'll he'll talk and and
the first time you it's one of those
breaths that when you're talking and
because you don't think about people's
breath when you're talking you know
you're just talking to them and then
when they start like if they'll lick
lean in and you just you don't even get
like you just you in your head you think
you think oh you know what I mean
that's the worst breath if you can get
somebody to stop thinking about anything
and just go like this
oh that's the worst breath his breath
smells like the [ __ ] inside of a
turtle probably and and he's got a
[ __ ] Indiana Jones outfit on and and
I know [ __ ] my buddy goes to the
coffee shop there and any [ __ ] he
direct messages me on Twitter once and
he was like check out this guy that's
always at the coffee shop that just like
Indiana Jones his father with the turtle
breath and he [ __ ] isn't like a legit
is on that Megan's Law or is that what
that is the child molester website
Megan's Law right I think that's the the
whatever the child molester [ __ ]
Megan's Law he's on it he like is a
registered sex offender oh he's a
registered sex offender hey he dresses
like Indiana Jones his dad his breath
smells like a turtle and he's a
registered sex offender a worst guy ever
I mean dude come on dude if you're a
child molester don't have bad breath -
what the [ __ ] yo okay so so yeah so
that's so but and and here's the thing
though so I started looking
up the on Megan's Law the [ __ ] [ __ ]
by the way my producer left he was
laughing so hard because of [ __ ] I
don't know what but it's as if the bad
breath thing I think but so he he he's
gonna blow his nose or something or
maybe just cry but um so so the guy
comes so the guy so I checked Megan's
Law and and I'm looking at this website
and you can like look in your area at
least in LA I don't know if they have it
everywhere but like you can look in the
area of where you are and see registered
sex offenders and it's [ __ ] up because
like this guy like everyone's on there
like if you have child pornography
you're on there if you have like fondle
that I feel even bad saying this but
like it happens like if you if you do
salude Act is what they call it lewd
acts with [ __ ] with with underage people
I'm trying to say it the most careful
not simple you're on the website too but
they don't tell you what the crime is so
like imagine like I might feel like
these days you can get arrested for just
like looking at a [ __ ] 16 year old
too long even if you're 18 so like
imagine being on the website if you're
18 year old and you looked at a 16 year
old for 30 seconds and also you have
like a van and Lourdes children in for
lewd conduct they should [ __ ] tell
you I don't know how to write like react
to this guy when he says hi to me
basically is what I'm saying like you
know if he just like was like if he I
mean not look it's all bad you know but
somebody who has a picture of a 16 year
old is you know there's a spectrum here
yeah okay that's bad that's obviously
bad and against the law and I don't
condone that for sure but if you [ __ ]
I don't want to say it but if you did
something way way worse than that it's
way worse I don't know man
I don't know how to treat him basically
but I do know how to treat him because
he's got the breath of a [ __ ] oh my
god dude it's like when your dog's
[ __ ] anal sac pops and you're like oh
he got that in his mouth yo dude you
have an anal sac in the back ear throat
hey dude do you have any intestines or
does it just go from your anus to your
mouth that doesn't travel dude
unbelievable it travels faster than
light the air goes through his anus and
comes out of his mouth faster than light
[ __ ] Neil deGrasse Tyson would be
like billions of lights it travels
faster than light from his anus all the
way to his mouth billions of traveling
particles made up inside him and inside
you make up the universe and smell like
a turtle the same billions of particles
that are inside of a turtle or inside of
his anus and travel at light speed to
his mouth and exit as he's telling you
about stickers on his on his table he
also has pictures of children and
dresses like Indiana Jones's father
if imagine if that was what will happen
in cosmos like I feel like nobody watch
like oh like 12 of those episodes and
that's what episodes 12 is about because
they get they get more and more like you
know in the beginning they're talking
about like the universe and [ __ ] and
time-travel and dark matter and [ __ ]
black holes but then they get to like
wolves and you're like ah you could
maybe just made six episodes there like
dogs are basically wolves millions of
particles inside dogs became wolves
I met Neil deGrasse Tyson that dudes
tall he's cool man that guy's got so
much hair to like on his head
he's got more hairs on his head than
people in China billions of follicles on
top of my head sprout billions of hairs
and they stay there they never leave and
that's what is known as my head
Neil deGrasse Tyson has more hair per
capita than [ __ ] trees in the world
millions of grains of sand on every
Beach doesn't compare to the millions of
hair follicles that sprout hair from on
top of my head that is what come what
has come to have us known as Neil
deGrasse Tyson's head dude
and you I feel like no deGrasse Tyson's
one of the guys that if we saw him bald
it would be like oh whoa no I by the way
I think I'm that way if I shaved my head
I feel like I might as well just jump
into a volcano but yeah dude how [ __ ]
weird is that they're around dude
chop molesters and [ __ ] and chop people
with their around their around it's
amazing it's just [ __ ] amazing I
don't know man
I see I see him all I see him all the
time and I don't know how to treat him
that's the thing you know it's weird
though when you're in Hollywood like
dude I've been in Hollywood for 24 years
I'm 36 I'm 36 I've been in Hollywood for
24 years
I moved when I was 12 with my family
and every time I say that when somebody
says I tell people I move with my family
and they say wow and I say yeah my kids
and I I think it's funny because like ho
12 real obviously does have kids and the
joke never works they don't laugh and I
just I'm always going to do it so buckle
down um and and I I was actually
thinking about this recently dude I've
been in LA for [ __ ] 24 years man and
I've seen people you see people all the
time that you see and like sometimes
you'll see people once a week like I see
this guy this lewd conduct guy once a
week but like then you see people like
once a year and like once every two
years sometimes but they're around
they're in Hollywood and they all came
to [ __ ] pursue their dreams right and
it came to Idaho because they were the
best looking person in their city and
they were like I could do it
come here and they don't do it or they
do do it were they kind to do it but you
see them around for like 24 years I've
been seeing these [ __ ] people some of
these people for 24 [ __ ] years and
they just get older and [ __ ] and I get
older to men and it's crazy to think
it's weird to see people to become
famous that were just like they were
just like Craig from someplace and then
it's weird to see people that you
thought were going to be [ __ ] so
famous and then they're just people that
are just like happy as like a bartender
or whatever which is fine too but like
their dreams didn't happen but they're
in the best place in the world it's just
weird to see these people all over again
some people just get fat some people go
paleo and they're thin and they look
like they their letters like thin as
[ __ ] but they're just like I'm on paleo
or whatever it's just crazy see these
people do it I had I've had roommates
I've had [ __ ] you know I thought ah
and it could still even happen for them
you know it trips me out it trips me out
to see these people that like make it
and then don't make it that guy the guy
was little probably like that the guy at
the cafe he was probably like I'm gonna
go to LA and I'm gonna become a [ __ ]
you know a guy with a Travel Show I say
that because of what he wears but then
he was like but then I saw some kids and
my life took a different direction and I
went to jail for a few years I know I'm
on Megan's Law calm adults are [ __ ]
weird man everybody becomes more like
themselves I think I've said this I
think I said this on the first episode
of the podcast but like everyone becomes
more themselves so if you don't like
somebody when they're [ __ ] 18 you're
sure as hell not gonna like them when
they're 35 and you're definitely not
going to like that when they're when
they're when they're 80 right like that
guy that you're like yeah I think that
guys that guys interesting I like that
guy if he's 25 bro that guy is going to
be the best when he's 50 because he's
gonna be so himself but then what
happens is like I was think of it in
terms of actors like like Al Pacino out
but she knows a great actor but if you
don't rein him in that guy will be all
over the place because he just becomes
you know people start doing impressions
at Al Pacino and then Al Pacino starts
doing impressions of himself and then
you're just seeing I used to do this bit
on stage where Al Pacino I feel like Al
Pacino only does movies where there's
like one monologue in it and it has to
be like a monologue that starts with a
story that pertains nothing to the
actual movie and then it ends up like an
emotional like [ __ ] scene like like
like the kid would be like hey dad you
know do you want to play catch and he'd
be like do you know how they make a Kobe
steak what they do is they take a cow
they get that cow Goodin drunk and then
they massage the cow they beat it up
nice I know what they do is they cut
that cow's neck they let the blood just
drain down my throat on a grill after
they skinned it and then make it nice
sure up like catch and you're like ah
that didn't have anything to do with do
you want to play catch but Al Pacino is
always doing these [ __ ] monologues
like that they'll be like which way to
the [ __ ] mate which way to Main
Street
I used to oh I used to have a motorcycle
like all right goddamnit can we just
don't ask Alfred erections you know I
feel like that's how he is in real life
you bet you want to change the channel
dude oh boy I'd love to yours to go
hiking in the mountains we used to see
bear and you're like God [ __ ] can you
just hit channel up dude I feel like
that's what Al Pacino is a so my point
is people become more of that like you
see that you see it with De Niro to his
face became harder and harder when he
would do it you know how we start doing
that a little bit what the [ __ ] is
printing something's printing I
literally have no idea what it is anyway
you did it
guys you get a little BTS here behind
the scenes um
the printer just went for nothing it was
scary but uh we're good so yeah
adults get weird oh man and then they
start like I don't know adults are
[ __ ] weird though adults are weird
you ever think about a [ __ ] weird kid
think about that person as an adult
that's how you know somebody's crazy by
the way is if you think of them as 75
years old and you think oh okay yeah no
for sure like think about some of your
friends and then think about them 75 you
really want to hang out that
[ __ ] dude think about your weird
friend then think about them 75 years
old and alone no weirdo weirdo weirdo
for sure but um I don't know why I have
this in my notes here adults who like
play games like actual game like oh
that's what happened cuz somebody
invited me to a [ __ ] party where
they're like yeah and we're gonna play
taboo and I'm like no no we're not you
might you're boring if you're over 12
you boring if you're gonna play a
[ __ ] anything with cards ah you're
boring dude you know how the games say
this is for 12 years and up they don't
save it's for everyone because of that
reason they say it's for 12 years and up
because at 12 you're supposed to stop
playing that game but they don't want to
say that because they want you to buy it
if you're 35 hey you play games with a
purple box did you buy a purple box with
stuff in it II you boring do hood did
you buy a purple box with thing with a
buzzer in it dude hey did you buy a
purple box with a buzzer in it and are
you gonna have people over to press that
buzzer and you're 49 go to sleep forever
don't invite those people over instead
go to sleep forever
[ __ ] that's the commercial for 12 and up
and if you're 50 go to sleep forever if
you think about buying it Tabo
Scattergories hey eat my [ __ ] if you
[ __ ] buy a red box with swirls on it
and it's got a hundred and fifty cards
and then you can buy another pack dude
here's the deal if you buy Scattergories
and then you play it so much that you
have to buy the [ __ ] extra cards go
to sleep forever go to sleep forever put
the cards in your coffin oh my god dude
you're gonna invite [ __ ] people over
to play hey do you have died do you have
died
do you have dice do you have dice in
your [ __ ] if you have any form of
dice if you have small dice that you
[ __ ] jiggle around in your hands and
then [ __ ] throw on a table and go yay
or if you have the furry dice that you
put on the rear of your mirror in your
car go to sleep forever dude come on man
Jenga die imagine being a [ __ ] 50
year old like oh god okay where do I
grab it oh no it's not fun just talk
play on your phone that's the adult
version go [ __ ] read or sigh you know
I don't know jump up and down for [ __ ]
sake get active ah
you played [ __ ] what's another one oh
you played Yahtzee yo what's with these
names - what we gonna call it
Yahtzee why cuz that's what you'll
scream when you win why cuz I'm a crazy
person ah hey yo what should we call the
game Yahtzee why sorry I have Tourette
syndrome well [ __ ] it that's what you'll
yell when you win Yahtzee we're all
crazy okay anyway we're going to sleep
forever why because we made this
drink this why because it's poison
dude come on man talk to each other I
mean what would you do like imagine a
group text hey having game having a game
time come on by Debbie great
if I tech dude I looked the other day in
my phone cuz I was wondering how many
contacts people have I asked somebody
they had like a hundred and fifty
contacts and I was like oh dude I have
way I I don't I never got rid of any
contact in my life I looked you can go
to the bottom of the phone look I have
two thousand five hundred and ninety
four contacts most popular guy in the
world I guess dude I have no idea who
[ __ ] eighty five percent of these
people are I got somebody named grace in
here who the [ __ ] is grace no clue
grace was by the way when I went I went
to lock in at a high school which was
like you everyone was either white or
Asian grace was the number one name that
Asian girls had and that's hilarious
because I feel like their parents didn't
really know when they came over here
what like American names were and they
were like they would like see movies
that were made in like 1960 like it was
like yeah well name her grace cuz that's
what like name that's what like like
nobody know like white girls name is
Grace this is like name of your kid
Henry or Hank Hank Kim hey Hank Kim you
know George suck George they would name
kids George
grace Hannah and like Hank Henry that's
so funny
like just what's wrong with the [ __ ]
David there was like - David Kim's and
47 grace lose they they they were they
were trying you know they were trying
but they did it oh I saw
it out dude God that movie was good hats
off to Jordan Peele
that [ __ ] movie was good would they
do it for like five million dollars I
made 14 billion dollars is like every
[ __ ] article like I read it's like
creeping up on Avatar oh man it was good
it was so good it was good because it
was like of the times to like everybody
yeah I feel like more people aren't
racist now but it's just being exposed
because of the internet and it's being
filmed I feel like everyone's been so
the most racist period but always but it
just is like so of the time because it's
like in a way like a on steroids racist
kind of like white family but it's just
so good like and it's cool because now
maybe they'll stop making [ __ ] not
that I really I go see these movies as
well too but like just these reboots and
remakes and [ __ ] I feel like they're
gonna make get out the reboot in it
comes out next year like dude you don't
like you just make some else
there's started a reboot [ __ ] that
aren't even hits it'll be like yeah the
rebooting [ __ ] Dante speak and you're
like that it was that a hit that was
what like Tommy Lee Jones I was like the
one movie Tom Lee Jones was in or Pierce
Brosnan was in was one is one of those
guys there were two movies that came out
like back to back in like 99 one was
called Dante's Peak and one was called a
volcano and they both ate utter [ __ ]
because you can't come out with two
[ __ ] movies about an exploding
volcano in the same year they're going
to reboot reboot that do it I'll do I'll
be in that make it for [ __ ] two
million dollars it doesn't even need to
be we don't even need to use real
special effects we could just use like
Tabasco sauce I'll cover myself with
Tabasco sauce and be like we need to get
down the hill dot
speak dude the reboot people be like
this but some of you'll be like this
move even kick wood I remember this
movie [ __ ] Dante's Peak and volcano
came out that'd be like transformers and
car changers came out fast in the
furious and fast and the angry came out
Drive Angry remember that one that was a
Nicholas wait was that was a Nicholas
Cage one by the way I was at the Comedy
Store the other night and it was like a
[ __ ] red carpet event dude it was I
say this because uh I think amber herds
in Drive angry and she was at the Comedy
Store Elon Musk was at the Comedy Store
James Franco's at The Comedy Store and
Leonardo [ __ ] DiCaprio was there the
[ __ ] they're like Chris you're on next I
was like oh [ __ ] okay I got to bring it
this could literally this set could end
my career and I'll never be able to buy
a Tesla it was amazing that place is hot
as [ __ ] dude I love performing there go
man you got to go to see like all the
comedians the top comedians for like $25
I don't know I'm not trying to make a
commercial here about the Comedy Store
but it's great they got food you could
eat that [ __ ] you can go and watch eat
chicken fingers while you Mitsy sure who
created the Comedy Store the owner the
Comedy Store never wanted food there
because she felt like it took away from
watching the actual comedy but they had
drink you know the to drink minimum
and now they got food there at the past
like two years because shits changing
man people eat the chicken fingers and I
think they got pizza or some [ __ ] by the
way that's some shut the [ __ ] up about
pizza dude pizza's great but shut up
about the [ __ ] Internet my life is
Pizza girls are doing [ __ ] posing in
Pizza bikinis and [ __ ] photoshoots with
their naked and they put them to a pizza
over there [ __ ] [ __ ] hey that's
gross as [ __ ]
ah man Pizza memes and [ __ ] it's good
but so sushi so it's [ __ ] you know a
taco a burrito
nobody [ __ ] it drives me nuts when
people just jump on the [ __ ] train
pizza let's sell pizza stuff Pizza shirt
that green frog eaten a pizza I had that
[ __ ] green frog get so popular with
the bug eyes I know I know he has a name
and other column something like Tommy or
some [ __ ] somebody said it to me the
other day like in life they were like
yeah it's like whatever his name is it's
like Tommy and I was like what and
they're like you know Tommy and I was
like nah what who's that and they're
like the [ __ ] green frog meme guy I'm
like you can't just throw that out there
like I know it like his name like he
exists like I see him sometimes on
sunset
Pepe is that it Pepe the Frog guy I
don't know Pepe Pepe I'm gonna google
Pepe meme yeah Pepe the Frog yeah weird
how that [ __ ] gets big but pizza dude
it's so good but relax and you know I
don't know I feel like the same person
who does that is the same person who's
like a self-proclaimed nerd because they
bought glasses and button their shirt up
that's another tired thing I'm like um
it's it's mostly girls I guess I'm like
the biggest nerd in the world why I play
video games yeah okay yeah what else I
love Star Wars have you seen all of them
most of them really why I don't know
they were just on did you wait in line
nah I waited for it to come out oh yeah
yeah I'm like the biggest dork ever why
cuz like I stay home so much oh yeah
mm-hmm
and I got glasses oh yeah mm-hmm
when's last time you [ __ ] yesterday
you're not a nerd god
when's last time you got you know you
went out on a date
when's that time you hung out with your
girlfriends I just got back you're not a
nerd
we're your pimples we're your [ __ ]
[ __ ] up teeth you know do you go like
this little globe you're not a nerd cuz
you played a [ __ ] fallout3 once
because you watched a guy play fallout
three once that drives me nuts oh my god
I like the bun like the most boring
person ever you know you're not cute
saying that [ __ ] so that my favorite
thing you do is like binge watch TV
you're not cute
saying it also I saw you out getting
drunk on your snapchat you know I like
never go out you're out you're saying it
at a bar why can't people just be what I
strive for this though in all
seriousness I strive to be Who I am it's
hard though I talked about this in my
last special it's [ __ ] hard not to
pretend it really is but try harder you
know try harder it's hard to even know
what you want right it's hard to even
know what the [ __ ] you want from the
very basic down to the very basic
element of it to be like it even to
realize you're tired is hard sometimes
you're go go go go go and you're like oh
[ __ ] dude I think I'm tired and then you
just like literally sit down and you're
like
it's hard to know but like try harder
don't [ __ ] lie to me and know you're
lying to me I don't like the cool guy
also that like tries to [ __ ] be a
nerd I don't know I got glasses I barely
wear them because I just got contacts
you know sometimes I wear my button all
the way up whatever
it's just don't pretend like you're not
who you are that's why I get upset at
like the chicks on Instagram that are
like on private jets and [ __ ] and they
don't show the [ __ ] dude that's
paying for the jet like the if you're by
the way if you're a girl and you fund
the private jet great I'm not saying
girls don't do that but these girls on
Instagram like 90
I don't know 90 you [ __ ] so much
percent of them are on jets because of
the guy that [ __ ] funded it and
they're showing the girls out there and
they're like with my girlies a guess I
guess dude
I mean hey you should always be winking
if you're like that like with my girlies
doing with my girlies any beat in Ibiza
Punk only hanging out with chicks
ladies night going you know like yeah we
get it man
but there's [ __ ] idiots out there
that are like hope you're having fun
baby you know I love goddamn love guys
from Dubai
that [ __ ] comment though and like
Russians or like a Croatian guy that's
like love to touch your milk eat it like
they'll just comment that on Instagram
like love
to love to press play on your [ __ ] and
you're like what what are these guys
saying dude it's like you really don't
have a great just do it in your own
language just write the [ __ ] Russian
[ __ ] love to press play on your [ __ ] BB
and then you go look and it's like only
pictures of the guy in his car and
you're like what dude goddamn people are
so weird man people are so [ __ ] weird
love to press play on your [ __ ] BB Oh
why the [ __ ] are people so weird it
makes it good I complain about a lot but
I guess I seriously love it like I want
to be friends of that guy with those
guys dude I met a guy by the way I got a
[ __ ] that's it man I got it I got I
figured it out man I love weird people
and I love I have weird [ __ ] friends
and some of my friends think that
they're not weird but they are but
that's what makes it so awesome dude I
got a [ __ ] Irish friend now he looks
like me but he looks like me but also
Splinter had a baby the rat from [ __ ]
and he cuts his mustache like half way
like I'm like dude why don't you [ __ ]
grow your mustache out or shave it and
he's like no I don't I can't do an Irish
accent but he's like I don't I I can't
do it but he's like I because I then I
look like a pedophile and I'm like dude
you look like a [ __ ] pedophile now
dude and he was like no I look like a I
don't know but I got an Irish guy and
he's so [ __ ] Irish and it's so funny
to listen to him and then I got a I met
a French guy the other day and I'm he's
my friend now dude he was supposed to
hang out with me Friday night I don't
invited him out to the Comedy Store and
he didn't show up this is what he texted
me let me just go through what the
French guy texted to me texted me first
of all he came up to me and he goes like
this he's got a weird accent and he was
like it was a-standing him I was talking
to my friend at the Comedy Store and he
was just standing near me like hovering
like he was a [ __ ] fly and I look
over at him and I say to him what the
[ __ ] going on man like you good and he
says uh oh hi um what what sure are you
going to see like that's how he sounds
it's not he does not sound French and I
was like what show am I gonna see he's
like yeah are you are
here for a comp for a comedy show and I
was like nom I'm performing one and he
says oh are you uh Chris D'Elia and I'm
like yeah I you just exposed yourself
man you know like if you like why'd you
pretend like you didn't know and the
whole time he was just I was like were
you from doing he was like France but
also I'm from you know what he's a
friend he's like this is a French you
know but that's not how he sounds he
said he's like but I sound weird because
I'm from London too and America and I'm
alright
so anyway I like [ __ ] fell in love
with this dude because he's like so
funny and he looks so he looks cool he
looks fine you know he looks just like a
regular guy but then he's like I came
here acting and like now that I'm done
with class I'll get a job like it's just
like so basic and I'm like yeah that's
awesome to see somebody that's so
optimistic and so French about it I was
like what's your name
and he says leo Oh a I should I should
say his name but his first name is Leo
his last name is
it's a French I can't even believe it
but anyway he goes like give me your
number dude you got to come out he's
like really I was like yeah so this is
these are the texts so far okay I got to
do the time stamp to the next day I text
him Leo my man it's Chris D'Elia
he writes yo what's up my man how's
going
I write good you gotta come hang this
week and this is what he writes back
it's a do my man yes can do and then he
writes a minute later it can be done ha
ye Y E with an a [ __ ] accent over the
e it can be done ha ye and then 20
minutes later I didn't respond but 20
minutes later he writes alright check
availability for it ha and I don't know
if he's asking me to check availability
for it or if he's saying he's going to
check 20 minutes later so I write
Thursday I write Thursday Friday
Saturday at the Comedy Store and then he
writes right after
Friday Broda I'm there k Broudy
I guess that's brother and then at 1:30
a.m. that night that was in the daytime
and then at 1:30 a.m. at night he writes
CL just the letters together CL and then
I write a minute later because I was
awake what cuz that's what your right to
that and then he writes a minute later
saws my bad typos I'll be at the show
yeah saws s o z and then 8 minutes later
he writes Friday as possible yeah and
then I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
getting that so I write you up and then
- oh no and then the next night like I
go to sleep and do my day and then
Tuesday at 7:27 p.m. then this is the
next day he writes ok Chris it was nice
to see a jokester like what what do you
mean like the time I met you like I
haven't seen you since
hey this [ __ ] guy texted me CL the
night before and then okay Chris it was
nice to see a jokester and then four
minutes later he writes and bobbly have
to check him the f out which he means
Bobby Lee and then I don't write
anything because I don't know what the
[ __ ] right back and then six minutes
later no but good dude Friday I'm here
and this is on Tuesday so I think it
means there so then I just write nice
and then a minute later he writes yes
good thing they're like this guy and
then a [ __ ] hour later this guy
writes it'll be good to go ha with an
exclamation point and then the
[ __ ] doesn't show up Friday
I mean he doesn't show up and so today I
text him you didn't come and then he
writes sorry had an ID issue and so
couldn't get drinks so couldn't really
go well so sauce bruh ha
hey ma'am who am i texting
did it really even happen is this a
[ __ ] malfunctioning robot by the way
this guy no doubt is my second best
friend because all this [ __ ] happen I
don't give a [ __ ] this guy is amazing
he is 100 percent I gotta get a him in
the Irish guy together sauce bro ha so
insecure too right ha at the end of your
text sauce bro ha hey man having a good
time over tea over here
ha who's he juvenile having a good time
huh sauce brah huh CL huh ok Chris it
was nice to meet you jokester huh and
Bob Lee have to check him the eff out
huh no but good dude Friday I'm here huh
Friday is possible yeah huh it can be
done hi yeehaw oh my god dude how's that
for a [ __ ] 1997 reference ah man ah
[ __ ] leo
you know god damn kid's name is Leo hey
man you're the most French guy ever
congratulations
I gotta talk to you guys about something
that I [ __ ] love all right I only wear
these [ __ ] underwear
okay it's it and I'm not telling like a
lot of times people do convert you know
I get to understand it I understand dude
I understand I don't know I think it's
commercials are terrible I think that
when you watch a commercial on TV
they're just all corny and dorky just
say what you mean so that's what I'm
doing here all right I got these
underwear okay
and they're they're me undies you gotta
try these underwear okay
and they're the best underwear I've ever
put on my on my on my between my knees
and my waist all right you guys got to
do this and you got to elevate your
underwear game to the next level with me
undies with me do it with me okay I've
done it already
get on board you did your wardrobe you
do it you do it right right you put on
the pants you get the pants you get the
awesome shirts you put on a hat if
you're a you know piece of [ __ ] but you
don't really think about your underwear
you got holes in them I know you do
you're probably sitting there listening
you got holes in your underwear right
now you get store-bought underwear you
get them in five packs some people go to
Costco and they get 95 packs this is
going to change your life for the better
though and I mean that these are me
undies dude it's the first thing you put
on it's the last thing you take off its
your underwear it's good okay I'm
telling you as crystal yeah it's good
they're soft they're soft as [ __ ] dude
you put it on it feels like butters all
over your body and they deliver it to
you the design in LA you know and it's a
it's a they make from the dude from the
physical micro modal and it's a it's
softer than cotton it's actually a May
it really is amazing
they got all sorts of patterns and I got
all the different patterns and you can
you know you could do it yourself you
can get your patterns and and and and do
it like that and in there and they're
cool they're not just dorky blue or
dorky white or whatever and if you do a
subscription you can set it up monthly
on they'll just deliver it to your door
and right now they're offering you a 20%
off your first pair and they can just
use um you can just like get on the
online do it right now if you got your
desk your URL is me undies dot-com /
congrats and that'll get you 20% off
your first pair 20% off me undies comm /
Congrats
so that's it man you don't want to be
wearing like a cool jacket in a cool
shirt and a cool jeans and nice Jordans
and a good hat and then you got on some
underwear that's holy what happens if
you're with somebody that you're into
and then they pull down your pants and
you got holes and [ __ ] stains in your
underwear dude
me undies dot-com / congrats get 20% off
your first pair and go revamp your
underwear drawer make the drawer look
nice do it I got all the underwear with
the different colors in the drawer me
undies calm / congrats me on DS comm /
Congrats
even though I just sounded Jamaican when
I did it like that me undies calm so
that's what's up
do that do it with me men catch me on
stage rocking a men you could see me by
I lift my shirt up a little bit and you
see the little pink one I got on I got
pink underwear it's cool men they got
all sorts but yeah anyway um God the
guys so French I got a hang out with
that's what I want to do do it I want to
have a guy for all of the I want to have
like that the McDonald's commercial of
friends I want a black guy Asian guy a
white guy guy from Ireland and then I
want like to just sit in a McDonald's in
a McDonald's and have the world explode
it's amazing dude um III just have an
Italian friend - I haven't seen him in a
long time he's really long it looks like
olive oil with a dick and he's just like
I don't know man I'm just real fortunate
man I get to hang out with all weirdos
it's just so awesome and you look
like neither the Irish guy people always
like highs I put him on my Instagram I
think or something
got my caveman coffee um what was I
talking about about the [ __ ] what
else did the French guy do we had him do
scenes in the at the Comedy Store like
me and my buddy Andrew Santino was
really funny in a comedian we had him do
uh a cop scene just test his acting
chops I put on my snapchat bro we were
howling I laugh all the time I only want
to laugh I only want to laugh I talk
about my new special how I don't want to
go to your birthday party it's just not
fun I only want to laugh I want to laugh
with my friends dude Joe Rogan said
something and he [ __ ] it stuck with
me I think about it all the time we were
talking and he says he's like my life's
a masterpiece you know and he's married
and he's like but my wife knows my
wife's a math my life's a masterpiece
and she's like it's awesome that he gets
to like live that this masterpiece life
you got to be careful though man people
try to take that [ __ ] from you they try
to [ __ ] suck it from you and they
don't know they don't even know they're
doing it man
you hang out with these [ __ ] people
they try to [ __ ] up your masterpiece
dude they try to put paint different
paint and like ya know it's a
masterpiece it's a masterpiece but look
what happens if you paint the house a
little different and then you [ __ ]
are like you know you're you're just a
human so you're like alright well let's
see what the house looks like a little
different when you know what the [ __ ]
house looks like you love what the house
looks like and some [ __ ] [ __ ] is
going to come along whether it's your
friend or your your your accountant or
your manager or your wife or your
[ __ ] girlfriend and they try to [ __ ]
it up man they try to [ __ ] it up cuz
they think they know what's best you got
to find people in your life that let you
[ __ ] live your masterpiece do it
shout out to Joe Rogan for telling me
that man he said my life's a masterpiece
his life and I was like [ __ ] man that
resonated with me
[Music]
yeah it [ __ ] helped me do it people
want to suck that [ __ ] out of you man
it's [ __ ] do this do that though this
would be good for you and you think
about it yeah I'll try kam bucho you
don't want that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
me [ __ ] you
Rick how about when someone's like you
should read more [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
I'll read whatever I want don't tell me
what to read you know or no no that'll
mean that you can suggest a book but
don't tell me to read more cuz you think
it'd be good for me I'm happy dude
you're the one that's got the problem
cuz you're told me what you think I
should do no dude don't [ __ ] up my
goddamn get your acrylics and get the
[ __ ] out of here
I do watercolor this is my masterpiece
I figured it out dude yeah it's selfish
yeah it is selfish but that's not even
bad I know people are listening now and
they're like oh sad he's alone fine not
really dude I laugh all day long and
that the key ain't dead the key man he
dead too [ __ ] keys not what we're all
trying to do even if you got a some rude
boys around you or some sightings Drake
is a came out with an album and I feel
like he heard me talk about [ __ ] his
[ __ ] on my last podcast even though I
know he didn't and and then was like
okay site ting overload ting overload
unbelievable Drake's just Jamaican now
that's it that's how it goes I'm going
to look at a some hashtags here cuz
we're rounding up on 50 minutes here let
me get up in this I used to have a buddy
that would say
uh you havin fun up in this piece I did
I feel that was the beginning of me just
being like alright well I'm gonna start
to hate lots of [ __ ] now you havin fun
up in this piece
what don't just use different words for
words it's [ __ ] we tried so hard to
make language it's not a piece it's a
room it's a bar I'm gonna hit the hash
tag here I'm gonna go to the cache tags
um how about this last one what's with
Lou the long silences on the podcast
that make me feel like I paused it so I
checked then I get mad congratulations
pot hey joke's on you joke's on you
kawaii potato change it that's her
[ __ ] name kawaii potato that's that's
cool but change it wonder what your name
is going to be next week because not
going to be kawaii potato that's bad um
[Music]
how about some of these questions
Ian habit fine that's not a bad name
Chris the guy just moaned very loudly at
a urinal next to me ever experience
weird bathroom [ __ ] like this
congratulations pod-like that's the
question he wants to ask like this guy
took a piss and then some guy in the
stall just went oh and he was like gotta
ask Chris about it on the podcast that's
weird
but I appreciate it he inhabit one time
I was taking a piss and this guy oh no I
was waiting to take a piss and this guy
in in front of me I guess I was standing
too close to him and he turns around he
says hey man how about you give me givin
me some room and I was like I'm not that
far away from you like really bro well
this guy's acting like I was trying to
grind up on his [ __ ] ass I feel like
I wasn't in the wrong there I don't know
how about
though the Donald Trump picture his son
I don't know his son's name because I
refuse to learn it but the picture of
him chillin on that stump dude how about
don't take a picture like that because
everyone's gonna hate you I mean even if
you like tree stumps and like sitting I
mean that guy literally is sitting like
he just finally got to a toilet and
squirt is squirting out diarrhea but
also kind of being like but I'm still
chill though and it's such a bad pose
was it setup was it like a photo shoot
you [ __ ]
dude what is going on with that photo
shoot it's it's the worst photo I've
ever seen in my life and this guy took
it it was like yo let me chill on the
stump dude grab a shot and you're the
president's son already people are going
to hate you and you have the [ __ ]
audacity to take that picture google it
I don't know what his name is who cares
the guy looks what it does Don jr.
Donald Trump jr. that's his name whoa
dude bro cool it cool it bro your name's
Donald Trump jr. and you got that pose
going on in the middle of the woods on a
tree stump and you're the president's
son hate ya hate Jeff forever for that
photos and more that's it you took that
photo you thought it was a good idea and
it's out there I hate when I have
there's historical photo I follow
historical photos on Twitter and it
drives me nuts because they'll be like
rare photo of John Levin not John Lennon
hey it's not rare because it's on the
internet it's not a rare photo if it's
on the internet because it's a link now
not hard to find it's not in a shoebox
somewhere in an attic in [ __ ]
Greensboro North Carolina where I have a
show coming up
see I plugged it but so annoying rare
photo of Tupac nope
dude Donald Trump jr. dude come on how
about George Foreman named all his sons
George didn't that happen oh God
George you ever see a commercial that
invent helped commercial every Hotel I
go and I turn on the TV that's what's on
immediately my friends ask me how do I
get help with a new product they say
George what do I do for my new product I
say call my friends I envy him he
doesn't say invent help he says invent
help I mean even the [ __ ] invent help
people were like oh god should we tell
him no he's crazy all of his sons are
named George um okay this guy Wow
this guy sends me one first of all looks
like a guy that plays Dungeons and
Dragons so he does in my head his name
is um a a plumb b-bomb okay I mean fine
obviously change it but whatever not
that offensive please answer questions
asked during the week not just the most
recent ones too easy to game the system
[Laughter]
bro I mean I don't care you know okay so
let me scroll back further like just
just ask on Monday then or like when was
this tweeted March 14th what was March
14th and and this is tweeted on a
Tuesday which is the worst day to
tweeted because it comes out early
Tuesday morning which means I obviously
recorded before that I found it though
because my producer sent it to me please
answer questions
during the week not just the most recent
ones too easy to game this system what
is this [ __ ] the NFL hi bye Wow a
plumby bomb came out with that [ __ ] a
suggestion bro
amazing everyone's asking me what the
[ __ ] in Drake's new album is like come
on here we go um uh what else we got
yeah I get it people send me all the
time uh fashioned [ __ ] like and it's
just so like people just my dams are
overloaded with [ __ ] um people with
like big jackets on and [ __ ] dummies
[ __ ] hats it was 9 million people sent
me that uh ASAP Rocky [ __ ] we look at
traffic cone blown up god damn I might
have favorite is when people come to the
rescue
dude you're gonna [ __ ] on someone for
bye yeah but he's Moore's except by ok
but he came from by go bed hmm um here
we go uh-oh here we go
would love to hear your opinion on
Jordan pills get out already told it
very good [ __ ] ten out of ten so good
um God [ __ ] did you see uh go to my
Instagram a few posts back but [ __ ]
Big Sean with his [ __ ] Burger King
outfit trying to look all dope and [ __ ]
god dammit made me laugh it made me
laugh dude um can you talk about here's
one from Casey Han tonic bomb
Casey H zero zero five can you talk
about catch me outside girl on your next
podcast please roast her uh yeah it's
just sad kinda you know it's just sad
because of the girl like was threatening
her mom and people in the audience and
now she's got a [ __ ] 8 milli eight
billion [ __ ] followers on Instagram
and made it you know I mean nothing's
gonna happen it's not like she's going
to become a huge celebrity and it's all
gonna fade away but it's just like so
sad
that quote stop making stupid people
famous like you know just how about how
about just you know no at young Jase
another guy I [ __ ] already answered
it but this is a good one how about your
thoughts on the games yeah that came
what's the game doing hey game stop
showing the outline of your dick on
Instagram the [ __ ] hashtags to here
like I can't say a lot of them because a
lot of them have the n-word in it oh oh
some of them are so gross first of all
here Oh some of them time to break the
internet again Valentine's Day weekend
special does he what does this does he
take care of your kids
ill whaa this is a hashtag does he slide
under that [ __ ] like a mechanic and
tune it up with his tongue oh I mean
this is an adult and then he's grabbing
his dick I mean it's huge dude
rap hey rap take your hand off your dick
wrap or wrap and put your hand on your
dick but stop taking a selfie in the
bathroom with your dick half hard and
grabbing it
I like this hashtag it's for women yo
bro I got news for you
it's for whoever the [ __ ] look sort
of the [ __ ] looks at it now you only own
50% of yourself is if you post them
online 50 percent are for you and 50%
are for the people that look what else
Oh eat this is a hashtag eat her [ __ ]
like she made Jesus the Last Supper ah
gonna hell going to hell straight-up
Jesus that when he did a hashtag and he
had send Jesus goes like that Jesus
iPhone goes like this no no no Jesus has
a [ __ ] personalized ring it goes like
this
when he did the hashtag it goes way
about this sandy bringing him back a
pre-owned when you built this sit and he
checked it and it goes okay hey uh Saint
Peter send when the game dies send him
to hell immediately okay st. Peter goes
because mm okay
Luna's one run her baths until the water
is warm as a Miami morning in spring
hey dude what the [ __ ] you're grabbing
your dick what's happening here are you
crazy
you're crazy at what point do you just
become crazy but after you stop saying
[ __ ] like the first time you like you
know two changes like two times I'm a my
name is 2 Chainz alright that's wacky
but what point is like okay now you're
crazy person I'll do with one more
somebody just sent me a picture also of
Garth Brooks with his hat off which is
hilarious slick steph rao stuff well i
like to add yoko ono tweeted every end
is a new beginning okay cool that's oh
yeah oh really
that's cool someone was saying yoko ono
just paraphrased semi Sonics closing
time al-farouq spin Hey look
congratulations al-farouq spin al-farouq
spin his name is al rahman and his
handle is al Ruxpin good job bud thought
I loved this Wilson MacLean thoughts on
people saying not my president yeah he
[ __ ] is yeah is cuz you didn't
[ __ ] not not enough you voted yeah is
he he you president that [ __ ] orange
guy that orange guy who's got the Sun
that poses like he's an American Psycho
he's here president got run everything
through him now cuz he'd then vow
oh yeah yay he's he's
he's this syracuse mascot because he's
orange that guy hey you Prem not my
president hey oh cool sign nice shirt
you got there it's wrong no oh you made
a cute sign with a wooden stick and it
says not my president oh yo that's cute
you can walk around as much as you want
with it
gay friends to follow simple as that
dude if everyone in America voted
Hillary would have been the president so
it is that's why I [ __ ] the
republicanos they don't want you to vote
they want you to suppress that vote
oh we speak and rail [ __ ]
I like talking about [ __ ] politics
though ah whatever I'm just gonna chill
it sucks what whatever happens is but
you know I don't know all right I'm
gonna wrap this up I'm done that that's
officially done when you start talking
about [ __ ] the president everyone you
were great thanks for listening all you
guys are awesome dude thanks so much
you know it really helps if you rate and
review this on iTunes and don't not do
it just do it
it helps tweet about it Instagram about
it snapchat about it rate review it
subscribe really helps thanks a lot
follow me all on Instagram Chris D'Elia
Twitter Chris D'Elia
snapchat Chris D'Elia Adult Friend
Finder Chris D'Elia kidding not on that
that's for like sex or something I don't
know not on tinder not on riah not on
any of those dating apps if you find me
it's a fake
so yeah that's uh find me I'm always on
I'm always out
I'm on the road oh I'm going on the road
check my website for dates Chris D'Elia
calm
and use the hashtag congratulations pod
to ask me questions and I will try to
look all week for you alpha B bomb or
whatever [ __ ] your name is
have fun playing Dungeons & Dragons -
Alma rudeboys and side Tings have a good
one and also SIA the [ __ ] Nara my babies
[Music]
you